what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel
today um i'm gonna be talking about a
lesson that i learned from my dad
who is a multi-millionaire um before i
start
do not forget to subscribe to the
channel and ring that notification bell
that way you're going to be notified of
my daily videos
while you're at it go follow my
instagram um the link is in the
description
uh but it's just probably things but
with instead of an s at the end it's a z
so it's like my username wasn't
available someone took
it anyways i'm not salty about that at
all
um what was i saying so from a young
age my dad has always given me like
really good advice
and literally one of the wisest people i
know and
i was thinking today like not everyone's
lucky enough to have
a dad at all or even like a dad that
like gives good advice and
is successful so one piece of advice
that he gave me
when i was young is that to
follow what you're interested in don't
chase money
um chase follow what you're interested
in and chase
skills and
i took this idea because
i was working a sales job back in
october and i actually quit it to do
social media because that's like what
i'm interested in and like what i want
to do
and i'm so lucky to have a dad that like
supports that and tells me to follow
what i'm interested in because
at the end of the day if you're
interested in something and genuinely
interested in it
that's what you want to do that's what
you love you're going to become
better at it than everyone else because
it's fun
like i would never look at doing these
videos as work
never like i love doing these videos i
love planning out what i'm gonna do
i even the parts i don't like like video
editing as you guys
can see these are not well edited at all
but i even like enjoy that like i would
not mind taking a class on that
and i think that's where a lot of young
people go wrong
like they don't see the big picture and
the big picture is
i might have to bite the bullet i make
less than i would have made at my sales
job now
and i'm probably gonna have to bite the
bullet and really struggle um
for a couple years and not even that
much because i'm lucky like i have
parents that would you know let me live
with them take me in
um not everyone has that and i totally
acknowledge that but
i just know even if i didn't have that
i would prefer to struggle for like five
years and do something that i love for
the rest of my life even if it's
something crazy like acting
or music you know that not a lot of
people hit it big in
like if you could be happy and
do something like let's say you make no
money as an actor for five years
six years even seven years like by the
end of that seven years if you
really work hard and really put your all
into it you're gonna
have figured out a way to make money it
might not be doing exactly what you want
to do
just like me like do i know if i'm gonna
make it 100 as a successful youtuber no
i have no idea i hope so but even if i
don't i know 100
i could take my video editing skills my
personality i'd like i could sell this
to a company and go work for a company i
have no doubts
so i don't know guys chase your dreams
because you know my dad he chased his
dreams he did what he loved to do
he did you know what excited him i'm
going to show you i'm going to show you
where we live now
literally like hold up
10 bedroom 10 bedroom house
i'm gonna show you the front um
none of this would have happened if he
like took if he didn't drop out of
college
and screw the high paying job that he
could get
gotten he started his own company oh my
god
okay you guys can see it there's a house
full house tour on the channel
on top of that he has 10 kids
none of us are crack addicts or drug
dealers or anything crazy
i mean you know some more successful
than others
fine but i would say everyone
does fine or above average i would say
and that's
people with two kids can't even do that
so i don't know guys
chase your dreams build what you want to
build
and you might not make it but like at
least you can go down and say you
tried anyways love y'all don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
i also just turned on memberships and
you're gonna get a personalized like
shout out at the beginning of a video
for anyone that signs up so
yeah talk to you guys later